te saludo en este momento nos
encontramos en las afueras de la ciudad
de san pedro sula está justamente en la
carretera que conduce a la frontera con
guatemala
te informo que son alrededor de 1.000
alcanzando esta madrugada el destino
inicial es cruzar la frontera con este
hermano país centroamericano pese a las
restricciones que ya mencionaba tú que
este gobierno impondrá a los migrantes
que no cumplan con las condiciones por
ejemplo una de ellas es que porten una
prueba de kobe de 1995 espaldas este
grupo de migrantes en este momento están
atravesando esta carretera principal
rumbo al occidente del país ya en grupos
fragmentados
pero son aproximadamente 5.000 los que
han salido este día con destino a eeuu
también hemos entrevistado algunos de
ellos y están muy conscientes a los
peligros que se enfrentan en este largo
trajinar mira qué
y otros que aprovechan los camiones que
en este momento también
como decimos comúnmente acá en honduras
aprovechan el jalón para hacer un poco
más corta esta peligrosa travesía la
inmensa mayoría de los integrantes de
esta caravana son jóvenes
nos han dicho que viajando y el sueño de
poder mejorar las condiciones de vida ya
que no encuentran trabajo en este país
también hemos visto a familias enteras
que fueron fuertemente afectadas en
primera instancia por la pandemia del
comienzo 19 que los ha dejado sí
oportunidades nuevo el paso devastador
de los huracanes está ello está que
pueden actividades afectó a casi cuatro
millones con sobre ellos los integrantes
de la caravana con los que has podido
platicar te han dicho si saben lo que ya
dijo el gobierno de guatemala que
autorizó el uso de la fuerza si de hecho
tenga un todo parlantes se escuchaba
este mensaje de que tuvieran cuidado
incluso también en el punto de encuentro
pudimos ver a la cruz roja hondureña
realizando a último momento prueba kobe
para que puedan cumplir con este
requisito y que puedan acceder a la
frontera con guatemala sin ningún tipo
de problemas aquí podemos ver son
muchísimos los jóvenes que integran esta
caravana que viajan directamente hasta
la frontera con guatemala el objetivo
final repito es eeuu donde pretenden
ingresar de manera ilegal buscar un
trabajo y mejorar las condiciones de
vida de sus familias acá
país americano